I'm Peter Davis I've been pen spinning
since 2011 and most recently I won the
stand-up theme in the 2022 pen spinning
Olympics I've been challenged today to
break down pen spinning into 21 levels
of increasing complexity
pen spinning is actually a lot like
juggling you basically use your fingers
your hands sometimes your wrists and
arms or even knees to toss to spin to
throw the pen or pen shaped object in
any way that you'd like as a disclaimer
this is my interpretation of the
challenge level one charge the charge
uses conical rotation in one spot of the
hand but just spins conically in one
spot and conical rotation means that the
pen is not actually spinning end over
end in a full circle it's just tracing
out a conical motion on both sides of
the hand level two pass passes are very
simple tricks in pen spinning and you
might not even have noticed you doing
them yourself just in daily life they
involve passing the pen from one finger
slot to the next one and they can go
either over the finger or under the
finger in either direction the pass is
slightly more complex than the charge
because the pen is actually changing
position in the hand you have to clear
the outside finger that you're passing
from and then duck the other finger
under or over that involves a couple
more things you have to get used to when
you're really gaining fluency in them
next up wipers wipers are done near the
tip of the pen and that's because the
pen has to pass through the finger slot
with a half rotation and spin wipers to
me are more complex in passes simply
because they can go wrong in many more
ways if you're not near the tip of the
pen then the parts of your hand that
you're trying to pass through might get
in the way and stop your wiper and also
when you're near the tip of the pen
almost all the weight is on the other
side so controlling that momentum and
keeping the pen from slipping out of
your hand can be really difficult to do
on more complex wipers the triangle pass
consists of three different finger
switches you can hold the pen to start
in all three and then you lift one from
the barrel while it passes about a third
of a rotation and then you bring the
finger back down on the other side of
the pen while lifting the next finger so
each finger switch is a third of a
rotation and you're always gripping the
pen between two fingers as it rotates so
every full triangle pass completed that
is every three finger switches is half a
rotation 180 degrees each finger switch
accounts for roughly 60 degrees of that
and every two triangle passes you
complete is a full rotate station or 360
Degrees you're not fully gripping the
pen at any point so if you're off center
in One Direction or the other it makes
it really easy for the pen to fall out
level 5 Sonic the basic Sonic involves
charge which is conical rotation and two
different finger switches so you do half
a charge in one slot and then you clear
that lower finger down until the pen
comes in contact with the next finger up
and then as that charge continues that
finger that you move down comes back
into contact with the pen completing a
full 360 degree rotation you can also
make Sonics inverse you do a charge and
then you clear that finger up out of the
way and then it comes back down and the
middle comes into contact with it that
way and you can combine these modifiers
in a lot of ways you can keep the charge
rotation the same but switch the finger
switches which is what's known as
moonwalk Sonic and you can add a lot of
complexity in those ways level six thumb
around the thumb around is a trick
you've likely seen in TV or movies or
anime and it involves the pen going
around the thumb and then being caught
again with the index finger people tend
to mess up them around when learning it
is by starting too near to the center of
the pen so in a round tricks the barrel
of the pen has to trace over the entire
circumference of the finger or thumb
that is rotating around so to learn a
thumb around you need to start with most
of the weight on the pinky side of the
hand and then by the time you're done
you'll be on the opposite part of the
barrel for the rest of the levels we're
going to be incorporating pen
modifications weight and length can have
a big influence on the types of pen
spinning tricks that you can do and how
well you can do them and how difficult
they are to do these basically have
characteristics that make it easier to
learn harder tricks they have balanced
weight a little more weight toward the
tips maybe a good grip different pen
Spinners prefer different mods to me the
natural next step in complexity is the
backfall the backfall involves four
different arounds that are linked
together with passes all four fingers
are used and a back is done on the index
then the middle then the ring then the
pinky and in between each completed back
the pen passes under the finger from one
slot to the next in the early days of
pen spinning the backfall was a really
important and impressive trick that if
you could do it smoothly you were one of
the best these days people can pick it
up in their first half year of pen
spinning for the most part but to do it
smoothly with a light pen and do it
elegantly is still rather impressive and
tough to figure out level 8 index bust
the index bust is basically a continuous
around done in the index finger which is
just the same as a back but with the
opposite direction of rotation in a
round tricks the pen ends up in a
different position than when it started
so to make them continuous you have to
get back to that original position
sometimes it involves a bit of a slide
most of the time it involves a little
bit of air time to move your hand to the
position where the around began index
busts in particular are probably one of
the most common finishing tricks you'll
ever see in combos Having learned about
a round of Tricks the natural next step
of complexity to me is half around
tricks which brings us to the power pass
the power pass is a sequence of four
half rounds which can appear similar to
passes because they take up 180 degrees
rotation and the pen moves from one slot
to an engine decent slot the main
distinction between a pass and a half a
round or power pass is that the power
pass is what we call fingerless meaning
that there aren't two points of contact
with the pen so you're not actually
gripping the pen between two fingers but
it's sort of resting on one or another
and you can put forces in the pen in
different ways power passes down on the
back side of the hand involve four
different tricks the normal Power pass
involves the fingers curling from index
to Pinky and the pen moving clockwise
then power pass reverse involves those
same fingers uncurling pinky to index
and the pen going counterclockwise the
mirrored power pass involves all the
fingers moving in the reverse order
and then mirrored power pass reverse
involves the reverse of that one which
means that the fingers uncurl from index
to Pinky and the pen moves clockwise
you'll find that you don't actually have
to flex your fingers really hard you'll
just learn how the pen feels on your
fingers so that the angle is correct so
that you don't have to keep those
fingers out of the way quite as much
level 10 back 1.5 so as we went over
with the rounds when you begin in a
round you're in one position of the pen
and when you end you're in a completely
different position another way to do an
around after doing the same around is to
add just a half rotation of spin on the
back of the hand you can learn back 1.5s
on any implement but it's always going
to be easier to use a pen that's nearly
perfectly balanced the reason for that
is that from one back 1.5 to the next
you're starting on the opposite sides of
the pen so if those have different
weights it's going to be really hard to
get used to doing one after the other
next up cardioids
cardioid tricks are hybrids between
arounds and wipers but they actually
tend to be pretty complex and difficult
to execute cardioids are another way of
dealing with the problem of ending in a
different position than you started when
sequencing rounds one after the other so
the reason that I've put cardioids in
this position is that the number of ways
you can mess it up is pretty darn high
and you have to be super precise with
your positioning on the pen and the
margin of error timing wise is really
Slim up next dual pass in a dual pass
you might recognize the resemblance to a
triangle pass every execution of it is a
full 180 degrees but they're only two
fingers instead of three and this makes
it a lot more complex and a lot more
difficult to execute you'll sort of
learn how it feels to have the pen
spinning on one fingertip while moving
the other one and you want to stay
basically again right in the center of
the pen because you have very little
control of it so the momentum could take
it off of your fingers basically at any
moment level 13 power tricks basic power
tricks are sequences of tricks that are
all fingerless often involving a lot of
air time
I start with an extended thumb around
bust release times two meaning that the
pen rotates for a full rotation and a
half in the air
and then I catch it with the index I do
a half power pass to the pinky then do
that again and then release with the
pinky again in what's called a spread
and then I'll catch it on the thumb and
do a thumb around fingerlessly spin the
pen for half a rotation on these two
fingers that are curled known as a
spider spin because of the sort of
Spiderman gesture it gives release again
with the thumb around do the same thing
with a palm Spin and then release again
and then do what's called a haitua which
is where the pen goes around the thumb
rotates half a rotation on the back of
the hand and then is released off of the
pinky you'll see that I'm using a bunch
of power tricks that all use the same
exact direction of rotation and this is
the main way that people learn power
tricks because since they're fingerless
they rely heavily on maintaining One
Direction of momentum so that when
you're sequencing all these fingerless
tricks together it's really important to
keep that momentum going level 14
inverse power pass the inverse power
passes are quite a bit harder than the
ones that are done on the back of the
hand because your fingers can only Bend
in One Direction so if you were to make
it inverse perfectly you'd want your
fingers to bend backwards but you can't
do that so instead of having the pen
rotate on the curled finger every time
at each stage of the inverse power pass
the pen is only touching one finger at a
time and is sort of balancing on the
side so in the inverse power passes
since the pen is never resting on a
Surface you have to maintain that
momentum very carefully and have each of
your fingers curl or uncurl at the
precise moment that they need to next up
finger cross so far through all of these
levels we've had the four main finger
slots between the thumb the index index
and middle and so on the fingers proceed
in this order as they do on your hand
but you can actually cross your fingers
over one another so that the order of
these finger slots changes quite a bit
the best way to incorporate finger
crosses into your pen spinning is to
make sure they're active meaning that
they are touching the pen while they're
crossing over one another so if you have
the pen between the ring and pinky
fingers you have that pin within those
fingers as they cross over one another
and you get a full 180 degree rotation
level 16 one pen two hands so you don't
have to spin pens in just one hand a lot
of people involve both hands wrists
other parts of the body even but it's
very common for people to specialize in
one pen two hand spinning where one pen
is spun but two hands can be involved
either independently or interconnected
when you move into two hand spinning
some things will feel a lot easier than
they did originally and some things will
feel pretty weird it didn't come to me
incredibly easily it can be really
unfamiliar at first but you'll probably
pick stuff up a bit quicker than you did
initially because you sort of know how
the tricks work level 17 changing the
plane of rotation the first thing I'm
doing is taking a normal Power pass and
executing it so that my palm is facing
outward what this does is similar to
what makes inverse power passes so much
more complex when my fingers aren't
curling in this direction I don't have
this knuckle where the pen can rest and
spin and I have to have the pen touch
just one finger at a time I also can't
really see my hand very well and see
exactly how close I am to the center of
the pen and it's actually a bit harder
to flex your fingers fully when your
forearm is pronated like this the second
thing I'm showing is an index bust but
my hand is just flipped 180 degrees
upside down and this simply makes the
trick a lot harder because you're
fighting against gravity a lot more you
don't have the back of your hand where
the pen can sort of rest and rotate when
you're changing the plane of rotation
for your tricks you sort of have to
retrain both your brain and your fingers
to relearn exactly what the mechanic is
and what your fingers are supposed to do
whether that's fighting against gravity
because there's a lot more air time and
you have less of your hand to rely on or
whether it's just how different your
hand can feel when it's facing different
directions up next charge removal so a
lot of what we've been dealing with so
far is adding things adding more
mechanics adding more tricks charge
removal is sort of the opposite you're
removing certain things that feel
natural in order to make the margin of
error a lot tighter charge removal can
be pretty subtle and difficult to notice
and that's why it's actually called
Japanese motion sometimes because
Japanese Spinners used it a lot in a
variety of ways and some people just
didn't really notice or pick up on it
all that much so the way it often works
is when the Palm changes position when
you're doing passes or Sonics or rounds
or anything there's a natural charge or
half charge that's added in to account
for that changing of the Palm position
but with type timing and different
mechanics you can actually take out that
extra charge and snap your hand into
position and it looks really clean and
precise level 19 Advanced Sonic hybrids
a lot of pen spinners out there really
focus on very thorny combinations of
Sonics that require a lot of flexibility
really tight timing and might not be
that elegant I like to focus on ones
that involve maintaining a conical
rotation cleanly while moving the hands
very precisely so what I'm showing here
starts with half of a normal Sonic you
clear the middle down and you hold it
with the ring and index then it's
interrupted by a reverse power pass on
the middle finger so the index gets out
of the way you lift that middle finger
fingerlessly and the pen is about to
enter the slot between the index and the
middle finger then the trick is
interrupted again and while the pen is
rotating counterclockwise on the middle
finger the hand can rotate a little bit
out of the way you flick that middle
finger down and with no rotations added
re-catch the pen in that charge rotation
between the middle and ring fingers this
sort of thing is really useful because
often you have to get from one finger
slot to another one you can add in these
degrees of complexity to add tiny tricks
in while moving simply from one finger
slot to another one level 20 threading
threading is a concept that was recently
developed by a Malaysian pen spinner who
has extremely flexible fingers and has
been very very instrumental in
developing finger cross tricks threading
involves a non-adjacent finger cross
meaning that the fingers that are
crossed aren't right next to each other
there are a number of ways to fail one
of the ways is in threading your fingers
can just get stuck on the way through
and not make it all the way through if
you cross your fingers too much or too
little the actual finger cross can come
undone or it won't leave enough space
for a finger to go through and in trying
to execute these cleanly it's really
tough to make the rotation smooth having
hitches in your rotation while you
execute any finger cross trick is going
to be the case until you get really
confident with them
level 21 Advanced combos these are the
sorts of things that you'll see in any
pen spinning collaboration video at a
high level I try to add a good variety
of visual flavor changes in Direction
changes in Planes of rotation a lot of
different mechanics maybe varying the
pace some slow sections some fast
sections and that lends itself really
well to showing a wide variety of the
types of tricks that we've been going
over in this combo I start out with some
fingerless around reverses or backs and
then I change the plane of rotation to
do a mirrored power pass reverse with my
palm facing forward then I'll do some
simple wipers and passes to set up the
next section which is related to the
back 1.5s that we saw earlier the
direction of rotation changed and the
Palm facing up instead
to finish the combo combo and do some
quick passes and fingerless passes to
get the pen between my middle and ring
fingers and then do a simple Twisted
Sonic that then hybridizes into a more
advanced Sonic trick that sets up a
rotated index bust release finish
foreign
[Applause]
starting it is easy to get discouraged
because things can come at different
Paces for everybody but it's important
to realize that there's so much out
there that people can learn and
contribute to in 2022 the World Cup
champion team featured a pen spinner who
had been pen spinning for under two
years the great thing about pen spinning
is that you can really do it anywhere
anytime you can learn at your own pace
using whatever you want so I hope this
encourages you to pick up a pen a pencil
even a stick and start learning these
tricks thanks for watching
[Music]